اذا تحت ضغط الشارع والاحتجاجات
الاقتصاديه كما اشرت او كما كان يسمى
الربيع الاسرائيلي وهذا يقودنا الى
استمزاج راي الشارع الان ونرى وراءك حسان
مسعود حشود كبيره من المتظاهرين في الشارع
في تل
ابيب تماما خديجه هي واحده من اكبر
الفعاليات الشعبيه الجماهيريه الاسرائيليه
هنا وسط مدينه تلبي
المطالبه باسقاط حكومه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو بشكل فوري
والتوجه نحو
الانتخابات المبكره ايضا بشكل فوري وهي
المطالبات والشعارات التي ترفع في هذه
الاثناء هنا في وسط مدينه تل ابيب هذا
الحشد الكبير الذي نراه هنا هو يقدر
بالالاف في بالقرب من المركز الثقافي وسط
تلبيب وهذه الفعاليه تشير الى ارتفاع
وازدياد عدد المشاركين بشكل متواصل في مثل
هذه الفعاليات وهي تقام ليس هنا فقط في
مدينه تل ابيب انما ايضا في محيط منزل
ومقر اقامه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو
وكذلك في مدينه حيفا وفي شمال تل ابيب هذه
التظاهرات التي باتت تشهد مشاركه واسعه
باتت ترفع شعارات ومطالب ايضا متجدده
واكثر قوه شعار اخشاف الذي كنا نسمعه خلال
المرحله الماضيه ويعني فورا او في الحال
كان يرفع لاعاده المختطفين بشكل فوري فقط
ولكن الان بتنا نسمع هذا الشعار هنا في
تلبيب وفي مختلف الفعاليات المشابهه في
اشاره الى اسقاط الحكومه بشكل فوري والى
التحات مكره بشور وه بسبب ما يقول
الاسرائيليون هنا عبر كلماتهم وخطاباتهم
وا ايضا شعاراتهم عدم الثقه من قبل
الاسرائيليين بان هذه الحكومه يمكن لها ان
تعيد المختطفين نتيجه لاستمرار هذه الحرب
طيله الفتره الماضيه دون التمكن من الحصول
على اي او تحقيق اي من اهدافها سما تلك
الاهداف المتمثله باعاده المختطفين هذا
ياتي ايضا بالتزامن مع امر لافت برز خلال
هذه الاحتجاجات خلال هذه الليله تحديدا
عندما انضم المشاركون والمؤيدون والداعون
لوقف الحرب بشكل فوري ايضا الى هؤلاء
المحتشدين هنا وجود هؤلاء كان قبل قليل في
هذه المظاهره وقد
شهد مشادات كلاميه محد
عدد المارين يتواجدون ويرعون شعات تطالب
بوقف الحرب بشكل فور وايضا كان هناك كلمات
قبل قليل من قبل المتحدثين تقول ان على
اسرائيل ان تقدم للجانب
الفلسطيني نعم الان نعود لنسمع هذه
المطالبه الفوريه كما نرى على الشاشه كذلك
هذه المطالبه
الفوريه من قبل الاسرائيليين لاسقاط
الحكومه هذه الدعوات عبر الكلمات هنا كانت
تشير الى ان على الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان
تقدم للفلسطينيين وعودا باعاده بناء
غزه وقف الحرب بتنفيذ هدنه سواء كانت هدنه
طويله الامد او بايجاد حل مع الفلسطينيين
لتشجيعهم على اطلاق سراح المختطفين وفق
قول المتحدثين لاسما المتحدث الذي يظهر
على الصوره في هذه اللحظات هذا ياتي ايضا
بالتزامن مع تصريحات بارزه كانت لرئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي الاسبق ايهود اولمرت
وهو الذي كان قد خاض عام 2006 الحرب مع
لبنان هو كان قد دعى بشكل واضح الى وقف
الحرب بشكل فوري في غزه وطالب الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بالاستقاله كما قال انه لو
كان في على راس هذه الحكومه الحاليه لما
قام باعلان مطلب او هدف القضاء على حركه
حماس في ذات الوقت ايضا رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي ايهود اولمرت وهو رئيس الوزراء
الاسبق بطبيعه الحال كان ايضا قد ناشد
وطالب ب الاعلان عن وقف الحرب لاطلاق
المختطفين بشكل فوري ايضا وهو ما يتردد
هنا في الشارع